this is a production of cornell
university
well awesome thanks so much it's a
pleasure to be here i was
well i was preparing for it i was
realizing that it's almost been 10 years
since i first took soil science with
jonathan ruslanelli so that's
been it's been quite a while being
connected with this department and
learning from
all the faculty in this department so
it's a pleasure to be given the seminar
and of course we are to be giving it
virtually
and not being able to see your reactions
and all that but
i hope something funny comes up in the
transcript as i'm talking because i
already heard
saw some funny things so with that i'm
going to be talking
about characterization of soil health in
new york state the effects of soil
texture and inherent property and
cropping system
the effects of management and also some
soil health data analytics
work that we've been doing in the lab
nationally to improve
soil health assessment
so um the presentation is mostly going
to focus on this characterization of
soil health in new york state
which is just published in these summary
and technical reports
um some of the more recent work that
kind of
connects off to off of that which is
some more regional soil health analyses
in western new york and long island
um partnering with with collaborators in
those
areas and then the data analytics part
is going to focus mostly on using random
forest to model
available water capacity and ace protein
to help us simplify soil health testing
and make it cheaper
so here just to if you haven't looked at
the report already here's the
characterization of soil health in new
york state
there's a summary report which is
shorter and technical report which is
long and has
umpteen tables in it with with a lot of
data
so definitely check those out those have
both been submitted as
peer-reviewed manuscripts so hopefully
we'll be seeing those
sometime in the future
and obviously we need to acknowledge new
york state for funding this and everyone
that contributed to this
but for those that maybe don't have a
soils background
we know that soils have inherent and
dynamic soil qualities and these
inherent soil qualities is
is what is what jonathan and soil
soil pedologists spend their time
studying it's a combination of these
parent materials climate biology relief
and time in
in forming soils and this is one of my
favorite
soil pictures of soil profile hagerstown
soil profile
and it's extremely high res so good for
teaching in a virtual
setting and then we have these dynamic
soil qualities which are changes due to
human human use and management and when
we talk about soil health
we're really talking about these dynamic
and anthropogenic aspects of soil
quality
so you've you've seen harold present
a couple of these slides so i'm going to
go through this but we all
recognize the importance of soil health
through its ability to function and
provide services
and we can really think about the
importance of soil health through to
lenses both through kind of the
agriculture
and plant and animal health nutrition
side of things and and the ecosystem
services side of things
water quality climate climate regulation
um and on and on but more and more what
we're starting to think about
in the in the anthropocene is is
humans tremendous influence on on soil
resources
so yeah this interest in soil health is
driven by this renewed recognition
that soil is critical for for climate
for biosphere integrity for water
quality for food
security and we need to understand these
increasing anthropogenic impacts on
planets
not getting any bigger um so you don't i
don't need to go into too much detail on
this
you guys are familiar with the soil
health lab it's been around for a while
um through the years they've
the current iteration of the port is
really really
a nice thing to look at and
focuses on some practical indicators
that
the lab decided to go with over the
years
of researching many indicators and
interprets
measured values um within different soil
texture groups
and provides guidance for management and
and constraints and we've we've measured
the lab has measured
a really large number of samples so so
what we've been up to
recently is is really trying to get at
um
using that information both naturally
nationally
and in the state to improve soil health
testing and
interpretation and benchmarking and all
those things
so what we're going to spend the most of
time on is this recent
characterization of soil health in new
york state report
we had 1456
composite soil samples from zero to six
inches
from across the state you can see the
distribution of those samples
and this is not a statistically designed
study but kind of using modern
data analytics to look at these look at
these trends
and the indicators we're going to talk
about today
we did the characterization of all the
soil chemical properties as well by soil
texture and cropping system but today
we're going to focus on
the physical which includes available
water capacity
aggregate stability surface and
subsurface hardness which is the only
one that's measured in the field with a
penetrometer important to have the right
conditions for that measurement
and then the biological which is total
soil organic matter
active carbon which is kind of the
fraction of easily oxidizable
organic matter soil protein
which is the most important nitrogen
containing compound in the soil so an
indicator for
the organic nitrogen pool and soil
respiration which is a measure of
metabolic activity
so the first question um which we
we've known a lot is about about a soil
scientist but
is always good to get a handle on um for
for our region
so we wanted to understand how soil
texture which is probably the most
dominant
inherent soil property influences these
soil health indicators because if
the the point of soil health assessment
is to be able to assess
management effects on soils we really
need to understand
these base lines so we're not comparing
apples to oranges
so you can kind of see we have maybe
dominant
a lot of loams and in our most
productive soils
more sandy soils in long island but
i won't go into that so much and
um we know some of these indicators are
really influenced by soil texture and we
um recreated this graph from our data
and this could
easily go into a brady and wild textbook
he's exactly what you'd
see in there that
the medium textured soils especially the
very silty soils
tend to have very high available water
capacity
and we've also known for a long time
that
soil texture controls the amount of soil
organic matter that a soil can hold
basically fine silt and clay particles
help stabilize
organic matter against decomposition so
the more
more of those fine particles you have
the more organic matter you can
stabilize against decomposition so when
we
look at this huge range of soils from
across new york state
you can see pretty pretty sizable
differences between
coarse loam silt loam and fine texture
groups
and that this information is really
important because
we need to be able to
interpret within the texture group
otherwise we're looking at differences
that
that are going to totally mask the
effects of management
and additionally to organic matter i
think what's more novel contribution is
is is describing
these more novels biological indicators
by soil texture as well so
we have active carbon and respiration
which i'll also follow those same
same trends
um and so the i think the biggest
contribution of this
of this report and this this research
is to really try to get at how do
cropping systems
farmers management impact soil health so
what we did here
is um when every farmer submits a
soil sample to the soil health lab they
put in their crop codes of
the previous two years and this year and
what we did was basically categorize
those
into five different cropping system
groups so the annual grain
brought together corn grain soy wheat
dairy brought together corn silage and
alfalfa crop codes
pasture different pasture crop codes
mixed vegetable
mixed crop code and the processed
vegetables is a single
vegetable crop coat a lot of snap bean
production
summer squash transplanted cabbage
potatoes pumpkins
and this distinction was really
important um that we wanted to make
because
we wanted to distinguish between the
effect of
management in in these smaller maybe
less than five acre
mixed vegetable farms versus the much
larger scale
processing vegetable farms because you
can
probably imagine it's much easier to
influence soil health in a in a couple
acres than it is in
100 acres so that's what we did and you
can see kind of the distribution the
proportion by county of these different
cropping systems across the state
um kind of where our soils are the best
from
buffalo to albany we have mo where most
of our annual grain production is
and most of our processing vegetables um
and also a lot of dairy in western new
york
northern new york mostly dairy
um and hudson valley and long island has
more maybe mixed vegetable
vegetable production so we're a very
diverse state in terms of different
types of systems so it's
not as easy as it would be in the
midwest to try to
characterize but also helps us find some
differences more easily
so we saw this before so i won't go into
it but the significance of this is
basically
that these different cropping systems
have have um
extremely different carbon and nutrient
cycling regimes and tillage regimes
that that are basically influencing this
in pastures we have
90 to 100 percent of the biomass being
returned to the soil we have no
disturbance through tillage
so all so that organic matter is able to
persist in the soil a little bit longer
and we're not disturbing soil microbial
communities
on the flip side in cash crops
processing vegetables and
annual grain systems we are exporting
a huge amount of the carbon and
nutrients from the system
a lot of these systems we still have a
lot of tillage in new york and a lot of
erosion also
taking soil
topsoil and organic carbon from the
system and kind of intermediate to that
um figure that these dairy cropping
systems that
that have these longer rotations of
three years of corn silage three years
of alfalfa
are applying a lot of manure have yeah
perennial forages or maybe
having a net input of carbon and
nutrients because they're importing feed
onto the farm
and then mix vegetable farms which
usually smaller in size and are
tend to some of them a lot tend to be
organic so
they're using compost for their
fertility and a lot of cover cropping
um so here we're going to look at
the effect of these different cropping
systems on
different indicators and right now you
can see that we're just looking in the
loam texture
because we want to be comparing apples
to apples we know that soil texture has
a huge effect on
on on that indicator and those other
biological indicators
so here we see that yeah pastures and
mixed vegetables are
able to maintain a much higher level of
soil organic matter than
than annual grain and processing
vegetable systems and dairy crops were
somewhat intermediate
active carbon by cropping system so
pastures dairy crops and mixed
vegetables
tended to have higher amounts of easily
decomposable organic matter
for microbes compared to the processing
vegetable and what was interesting is
these were um these are both the same
samples but
there so dairy crop tended to have lower
organic matter than mixed veg and
processing veg
in in pasture but similar amounts of
active carbon so i don't
exactly know what that means but
interesting nonetheless
soil protein similars or total organic
matter
much higher in the pasture and mixed veg
systems
than dairy crop annual grain and
processing vegetables
and this is that an indicator of that um
organic pool of nitrogen in the soil
soil respiration the pasture soils had a
very
very high signature for soil respiration
compared
to these other indicators and we could
talk about that
why that is if people are interested in
that
and and what's really nice proof of
concept i think
a lot of people tend to just think about
the biological when we talk about soil
health but
aggregate stability is a really great
indicator for soil health
and um is very sensitive to these
different cropping systems so a couple
things
is going on here we we first know that
yeah undisturbed systems
with no tillage um that have living
roots all year
their mycorrhizal fungi are intact
and those fine roots and mycorrhizal
fungi are just really
huge actors in building and maintaining
aggregates in the soil
and we also know there's a positive
relation between organic matter
and aggregate stability so that could
explain why these mix vegetable and
dairy which
could could conceivably have the same
amount of tillage as the other systems
but
are maintaining a little bit higher
organic matter
and this is yeah nice proof of concept
because
big data set showing this in all texture
groups
you could probably pretty reliably go
take a sample from a pastor
take a sample from a field that's been
cultivated
maybe with low organic matter and and be
able to do this
slaking demonstration for your friend or
a farmer
to be able to show this concept
so when we look at all the soil health
indicators by cropping system
we see they're all kind of telling us
that
processing vegetable and grain crops
tend to have the lowest
lowest um lowest of these soil health
indicators
across the biological and physical dairy
cropping are
somewhat intermediate and pastors tend
to have the highest
um so the next thing we did which was
interesting and also a novel
contribution was to do this variance
components analysis
which is basically we have these two
factor levels in our data sets texture
group and cropping system
and we want to understand which one is
explaining
the variance of these different
indicators
more so basically what we saw
is that soil organic matter and active
carbon
the variance was about equally explained
by both the texture group and the
cropping system
whereas for protein respiration
aggregate stability
the cropping system factor level is
explaining much more
of the variance and those indicators
whereas texture we
saw earlier that very nice
clean bar chart of the effect of soil
texture on available water capacity and
it's a very texture controlled
variable which will come back to that
which enabled us to model it later
um so what what uses all this
information
i guess before i
did this we could having this
information
in the tape in the reports we also have
um
these tables by the different texture
groups
and this can help us um have us kind of
a further level of interpretation than
what we're doing now
to be able to kind of relate your field
um if you're a processing vegetable
operation on a silt loom soil compare
that to the mean
of of this database and have some
metrics for
for how you're doing compared to your
your peers in new york state
and we can also do a similar thing um
so unlike air and water where there's a
lot of
quality standards some those are more
homogeneous medias which are
easier to get a measure we have a
difficult job of
soil scientists of dealing with all the
variability in the natural environment
but
um these metrics are really common and
goals are common for other natural
resources so i think
as as we're realizing the importance of
soil
when we can use some of those use some
metrics and goals or whatever we want to
call them
to help farmers calibrate their
management and
maybe maybe these can be used in policy
to help us target
target um different goals and and we
need
and we need um it's really important for
us to be at the table as soil scientists
to
to make sure that these goals are kind
of adapted to region adapted to soil
texture
adapted to cropping systems because
there's a lot of
factors that go into it we can't just
say let's let's put a two percent soil
carbon
standard on all soils
so we can also yet develop these
aspirational soil health goals by
cropping system
um in similar use similarly using this
database
to basically target the 75th percentile
so 25 of the farmers are are reaching
this goal
for this soil type and cropping system
so that might be a good goal to aim for
if you were gonna
aim for a goal and we have these for
these four different soil texture groups
and all these cropping systems
so as
we are feeling the impacts of
anthropogenic climate change more and
more um
we're get we um the public and
and a lot of new york state is really
interested in
in building soil organic carbon as
as one climate mitigation strategy
um to to address climate change and
of course we know that soil carbon is
the kind of keystone soil health
indicator
so these things go hand in hand we can
do climate change mitigation
and and and build healthy productive
soils at the same time
and kind of what we discussed before
soils
greatly vary in their ability to store
carbon
both um based on the influence of soil
texture
um but also cropping system you saw that
cropping system seems to have a
play a large role in how much soil
organic matters in the soil
so we can use this information to help
maybe target soils of greatest interest
of
greatest benefit so this is going to be
a little bit detailed if
if you're not as close to this field but
i'll try to go slowly so um
there's a bit of literature on
on carbon saturation and
carbon saturation theory
and some equations to kind of predict
the capacity based on other things so
this
this is just one approach it's it's not
perfect
the carbon saturation is definitely
not a is is a little the targets are a
little bit elusive but
we can we can try to put numbers on it
and and show
some show some things so the both these
equations basically calculate
the carbon saturation potential
of defined fraction so the one that's
more more relevant for this paper is
less than 50 50 micrometers and
basically
we have the silt and clay content and
use a user regression equation to
calculate that and this is in this
six at all paper and this this these
were basically data sets of grassland
soil so we're saying that
that these systems are probably at
saturation and
there was these are their linear
relationships
in those data sets with the amount of
silt and clay content
so we can use those there's a really
nice paper that
that came out recently which basically
um
has a similar approach that we took um
for
for our new york data set but in france
where they have a huge amount of data
and and did a similar kind of approach
across different land uses
and then we could define the car the
soil carbon deficit is basically this
saturation potential minus
um minus what we have what we
reasonably have in that fraction um
and i'm not going to go into this in
detail but you can see that the
soc sat minus soc fine is going to give
us our
soc deficit and the most important thing
is basically to show this to show that
the different cropping systems um
are are further from this um
from this saturation point which is this
which is this red line here
um so these mixed vegetables and
pastures are closer to that line
and some some fields are are very close
to that line
um and i know there's a lot of
the confidence if i put the confidence
intervals on here it'd be
be quite large but still a useful tool
to
to show that annual grain processing
vegetables
a lot of those fields tend to be much
further um from the potential so there's
there's much greater potential in a lot
of these annual grain
processing vegetable fields for building
and sequestering soil organic carbon
so this is kind of an infographic we
made for the report
showing that
additionally uh harold's already showed
this but
if you're um more graphic learner
this is this is basically the same
concept is that
there's so much only so much capacity
for soils to
store carbon based on
the concentration of silt and clay
and management systems
so we tend to know what what works to
promote soil health
conservation tillage cover crops
perennial crops
organic organic amendments
so it's i think it's really about
continuing to do the work we do in
extension to promoting these
reduced tillage and cover cropping
practices
um to improve annual grain and
processing
vegetable systems and bring them up to
to what those other systems which
already have a lot of these components
in them
to them beyond improved soil health so
perennial sods manure compost
application
on the far right i mean what's really
exciting in being in this extension
field is
is the amount of thought and farmer
innovation
research going into the integration of
reduced tillage and cover crops and we
have
our own expert here matt ryan who does a
lot with
no-till soy no-till organic soybeans
there's a lot of interest in planting
green
bio-strip till which is basically
using precision ag to plant different
strips of cover crops one will winter
kill one won't and you can plant
your cash crop directly into that so
to to wrap up this characterization of
soil health in new york state
the key summary points are basically
um we can show the effects of
inherent soil properties like soil
texture on
soil health indicators which is really
important baseline of information to
have
and also that cropping systems with
their associated carbon and nutrient
cycling regimes and soil disturbance
have a huge impact on these soil health
indicators
and these metrics can help us um
benchmark farmers soil health
um in a more kind of realistic cohort so
it's not
as useful to compare a annual grain
field to a mixed vegetable field but
being able to um yeah compared to
a cohort we can provide aspirational
goals
and and because we had such a soil
texture rich database we can
kind of do some assessment of soil
organic carbon
storage potential across these different
soil types and cropping systems
so
next up and this is work kind of
bridging from this
larger characterization of of soil
health
um and this is this is work that's
that's ongoing
i'm working with debbie aller in in long
island suffolk county
and orleans soil water district
soil health western soil health alliance
to basically probe into certain regions
of the state
and with that we can partner with people
that
know the operations really well know
maybe help us improve and and make our
categorizations more
local and maybe they can help us with
their relationships with the farmers get
get additional information cropping
cropping history information
organic amendment um input information
to help
fill out in information and understand
the effects of these
management practices on soil health
so we'll start with long island
and there are no annual grain farms or
dairies
in suffolk county but um long island
agriculture brings
brings different things so there were
actually some
kind of woody plant um operations
um these are like christmas tree farms
and different things like that and and a
bunch of perennial fruit so those
those were also included as well and
um this part of the presentation is
definitely
not refined yet i might further refine
these cropping system categories with
debbie owler's input but we can see
similar things
now we have the perennial fruit but the
single vegetable crop fields tend to be
much lower than these
mixed vegetable perennial fruit and
pasture and we're just looking at silt
loam
soils here
so here's just active carbon by cropping
system
and these pastures and and perennial
fruit operations and
mixed vegetables are maintaining um
higher amounts of easily oxidizable
organic matter in the
top six inches due to organic
amendments or a lack of tillage compared
to those processing vegetable systems
respiration a similar high signature for
pastures compared to
vegetable operations aggregate stability
this is
just really um interesting and nice to
see
how consistent um aggregate stability is
performing across these cropping systems
um and yeah obviously these undisturbed
systems tend to have much higher
accurate stability than systems that are
maybe tilled or have less organic matter
um so now we're moving on to the western
new york part
and we've been um i should have only
showed one side yet but we've been
collaborating with franklin egan and
saranawa at
pasa and they've been doing this really
large
um maybe the largest of like
um a cohort oh not the largest but
um a large large cohort in pennsylvania
and northern maryland
of growers who are submitting samples
maybe
every other year and then
having them in different cohorts and
what they did is
they did a bunch of individual reporting
which
which which i really liked um so in
addition to
kind of the information we gathered they
were gathering things like
um days of living cover how much are
your organic inputs
and they were kind of plotting plotting
a farmer's field so they would give this
individual fee
back to the farmer and show how their
organic matter inputs
compared to their peers or how their
aggregate stability compared to their
peers
um so um in and that relates to our
western new york project because
we have a nice collaboration with
orleans soil water district
in 2015 they submitted 45 fields
and then last year we we
sampled and resubmitted those those
fields again
um so i did did kind of a similar thing
for a couple of the indicators
and kind of show um where they were at
in
2015 and 2020 and compared to their
peers because i think that's
that's the most useful information we
can give um
because this although it's anonymous
it's it's more personalized
these are the neighbor neighboring farms
in orleans county
um so how do cropping systems
impact soil health in in orleans county
and
in some of the surrounding counties um
you can see that that most of the
operations are annual grain or dairy or
processing vegetable
so i think there's a lot of potential to
to refine
these cropping system categories to make
them more specific
um to a region and we know there's much
more complexity than just
calling something annual grain farm a
dairy farm or a processing vegetable
farm
there's annual grain there's there's
just processing vegetable farms and
there's annual
there's farms that grow both annual
grains and processing vegetables
in the same rotation there's there's
people that just grow the cash grains
there's people that grow annual grains
in a in a dairy rotation
people that are more strict dairy so
we're still
refining this but this is kind of the
level
level that we want to go to be able to
break out some of these
trends and this is maybe more useful for
orleans county but also nice to see this
proof of concept the strong influence of
soil texture on these biological soil
health indicators
um and what we're starting to see in
this western new york data set this is
for loam soils in in western new york
in orleans county and for surrounding
counties
basically the systems that have
vegetables in the rotation
things like cabbage and pumpkins tend to
have
lower biological health in this one it
showed up in active carbon and
respiration
compared to systems um that have
that are more dairy rotations that might
have a
perennial forage or have the corn silage
and
potentially also have manure so that was
the next
another piece of information that k.d
somerfeld helped us
extract is whether these fields have
history
manure history and you can see
despite these uneven sample sizes that
the fields that had received
manure had higher soil organic matter
and respiration
than if they had not okay
so next on to the data analytics part
this is much different than the
previous part of the presentation but
basically
we have a very large data set with
with a lot of parameters measured per
sample
and um there's a lot of interest in
in using in in developing models to
predict some of these indicators that
are more costly
um and time consuming to measure
so most of this is going to be about
using random forest
to model available water capacity and
base protein
but before we do that just a little bit
of information about this
very massive national corn also health
database this is
the sample sizes that it looked like a
couple years ago
um subset has has some gps information
and we're i'm sure some of you remember
marcio nunes we're
still working very closely with him now
he's with the usda irs and
other usda ars and nrcs researchers
to help use this information to advance
soil health testing and interpretation
across
across the country so
without digressing too much from the
rest um the random forest i just want to
show you this this
was just um the final version was just
accepted
yesterday and so we have
moving forward with the national
comprehensive soil health assessment
and smaff was kind of the usda ars's
approach and
and cash approach and now we have um
this acronym shape soil health protocol
assessment protocol and evaluation tool
which
kind of merges those with some more
advanced statistical
methods and a much larger database
that's
nationwide so this this data set had
something like 27 000 observations
combining our observations published
studies
and and a lot of nrcs
data so basically what this
is here i'll just read this sentence
verbatim because
it says it more concise than i could say
it so the scoring
basically using some bayesian model
estimates
of to define this conditional cumulative
normal this
cumulative distribution function for
each cohort of samples so we're
using main annual temperature data
meaning
precipitation data subwater and soil
texture and right here i've just
kind of honed in on this was the
there's basically five of these figures
in the table
for each different soil texture group
that they have
and um the suborder s4 is kind of
kind of like what we have in new york
state but you can see the
influence of of the of the different
climates
um so if you're in a very hot and dry
climate
two percent soil organic carbon is
extremely good
um if you're in a maybe climate like
ours
um then it might be around fifty percent
and then if you're in a much colder
climate then that might not be as good
so this is a really nice approach that
allows
the same scoring approach to be able to
be used for any point in the continental
us okay so now to the actual
prediction of available water capacity
um regression is a wonderful tool but
if you're if you're really into getting
as as good prediction as you
as you can traditional linear regression
techniques can only get you so far with
prediction
you can see us maybe explaining 61
percent of the variance
seems like sand is the most important we
have a really big database here so we've
been using random forest
um to to predict available water
capacity for two years in the lab
we're explaining about 10 10 more
variation
and um the rmse kind of tells us that
we have that the prediction is about as
good as
as the accepted variance that we would
accept um
between replicates in the lab so it's
it's a pretty good
pretty good model and we have a lot of
the predictors
from the soil health assessment in there
so let's um if you haven't heard of
random forest
it's um becoming a very popular machine
learning
non-linear method um
and and basically these decision trees
i made a decision tree for awc is
is kind of the basic building block of
random forest
but this isn't actually the model we we
use because the model is
more complicated than that random forest
is basically taking a random subset of
the predictor variables
in a random subset of the data and
making
a lot of these trees about 500 trees and
in my case and then the random forest
assembles
the many trees to come up with the best
prediction
and um
this is if you're into random forest
this package random forest explainer is
really wonderful
because unlike um linear aggression
which is
much more mechanistic you can see
the coefficients for the model for each
variable
this is a little bit more black box so
there's some really nice diagnostics
you can get and and which makes sense
with how much we know
texture controls um
controls um
um awc we see sand and silt are
really high up there this is basically
that
the when it's running the summarization
of running those 500
iterations of the random forest so if
we're at node zero it means that
the sand and the silt tend to be the
best
indicators for that that top of the that
top of the decision tree
and followed by organic matter and clay
and another tool that i use to help
visualize the effect of these different
predictors in the model
is to kind of use use a construct a made
up data set where
just one thing changes it um at once
then you can run the model and see
basically how that single indicators
being used in the model
so this helps us visualize it and this
is this is nice
from soil physics and harold and bob
could explain this better than i can but
basically once you get well basically
all those
coarse textured soil those soil texture
classes those coarse soil texture
classes
a lot of them that definition is at 50
so once you get
more than 50 percent
sand in the soil that's when you're
starting to get sand against sand and
creating
more of those bigger pores which which
have a negative
relationship with available water
capacity also
positive no um
and also of of huge interest is
we talk about this a lot and um
in extension and people want to be
managing their soils for greater
available water capacity
um but at least within our model and
some other work
has shown help this this work helps us
visualize that
soil organic matter has has a much
greater effect of improving
available water capacity in coarse
textured soils
compared to silt loam which already has
a pretty good amount of available water
capacity
and i'm going to stop there it seems
like that's the
that's the perfect time to cut it off i
had ace protein but we'll just skip that
so plenty of time to take questions if
people have questions
and definitely want to acknowledge our
our large team
harold venice bob kiersten kurtz
david wolfe galia barshad who made some
of those beautiful maps
marcio nunez who i'm still closely
collaborating with
katie sommerfeld dennis kirby in orleans
debbie owler and
long island franklin egan from the
pasa inspiration and all the wonderful
people in the lab
thanks a lot joseph that was excellent
the floor is open uh
i think david roster you have your hand
up so why don't you go ahead
joseph thanks a lot very interesting
your very last thing you
presented it seems you could convert
that to
actually a value of this with
drought resistance if you fed this into
a simulation model
and you say well with certain climate
scenarios if you have this better
available water capacity
you're actually going to get this much
higher yield so
you could go one step further with the
say the improved water capacity
what does it really give me so you've
shown the water capacity what is really
the effect of this
and the bigger effect presumably would
be getting through those drought periods
in august for example so it's just an
idea
because i think one thing missing in
this whole health soil health story in
general
is the link to really the the the final
value of having a healthier soil
and this would be one way to actually
get to that so it was just a comment now
that's enough for
you don't really have to respond yet no
that's great no that's definitely one of
the challenges of
just requires so much information in
such large data sets to be able to pull
together information and i think
hopefully with more of these
regional partnerships we can start
hopefully maybe getting some of those
linkages and linking linking this
information to yield
which is it's really important
johannes you have your hand up thank you
thanks joseph uh good to see all this to
come together it's so exciting great
presentation
um i my question follows up on on
what david just said um the
quantification of
uh you know what's good what's bad and
how does that translate into a
management in any quantitative way
has been a little bit of a stumbling
block so what what do you think
or from my vantage points um
what's the response from farmers in new
york or elsewhere
but maybe specifically in new york state
that see these values
and and in the first instance as as you
mentioned compare them to their
neighbors
or the cloud of their neighbors um
but but how do they translate that into
action
and what can you learn from from these
responses of farmers
um that maybe translate at some point in
in a quantitative
recommendation system that says well if
you have that value
in active carbon you have to change your
management to x
um yeah it's definitely a complicated
question
and i think i really like to pass a
framework where in their report they
have
they have those steps that you would
take to change your management oh
my days of living cover is much less
than my neighbors days of living cover
so i think those tools can also be
helpful
in making and making those linkages more
explicit um but i think we're just at
the beginning of um
maybe providing more useful information
for for peers for people to get
have help help peak people's interests
more
because if it's just
just a score based on soil texture
that's maybe not as interesting as
having us us having data from your
data from your peers so i think yeah i
think the jury's still out and we're
we're working to try to make it useful
and
useful to everyone but it's not easy
thanks julie thanks johannes
there's a question in chat from from
peter woodbury
thanks joseph can you say anything about
bulk density and
also address the issue of depth of
sampling for for these
these samples yeah so the
can't say anything really about bulk
density um
it's possible someone could trample the
soil and then their six inches is
is maybe different than really six
inches but
the a lot of the samples collected in
this are
are collected by by professionals that
know what they're doing and
the sampling sampling
procedure is pretty clear we all the
samples are
zero to six composite samples
but sampling is really important if you
wanna
we talk about sampling a lot because
unlike
nutrient nutrient analysis where you can
it's much cheaper and you can do grid
sampling across a
100 acre field for this more detailed
analysis it's
you really want to be targeted because
the variability in the field can swamp
what swamp the
swamp the pattern so
um yeah so i can't say anything about
bulk density but
depth of sampling um
should be zero to six inches thanks
joseph we have another hand up uh
david go ahead hi joseph thank you for a
nice presentation i i was just wondering
is there any interest
on your part or vice versa
with the forestry industry and adding
some
depth to site indices that are
traditionally used as a creation of
the quality of or the the
cutting cycle for cohorts or different
cuts
in logging um i don't personally want
to um go there because it's a whole
different
uh there's people that have done a lot
of work and for
soil health um
yeah it's just for me it seems like such
a dramatically systematically different
system that
at least i want to try to focus on more
agronomic and
maybe maybe perennial fruit is is the
furthest
um um i'm currently interested in going
just because
the considerations are so different and
i've seen some
some very different um relationships
with forest soil health and
maybe more agronomic soil health with
bulk density not having effect on tree
i don't know it's just it's it's more
more complicated or it's much different
than
than than agronomics
there is some good work out done out
there on that
uh we've got a couple well harold i
guess
harold's hand is up and and joseph will
release you in a second i know that
we're now over time but harold please go
ahead
now i just wanted to make a quick
comment um
i can't help but reading the subtitles
and the speech recognition
it recognized michael reisel fungi so
you're pronouncing it correctly joseph
and i'm impressed with the speech
recognition software
we've made progress folks
but i'm not from
so africa last question from my side to
the short one and then we'll close but
i'm curious if you
have uh crop performance data from from
these sites and if you put that into an
integrative analytical framework we
don't have um
crop yield from those sites i think that
would be
i mean hopefully be maybe a next level
where we can collaborate
more closely with orleans soil water
conservation districts and
and propose that but a lot of the
information is out of our hands so it
requires
requires coordinating and and making
these partnerships to
link the data with um link the data with
yield information or plant performance
information so that's
that's that's definitely i think yeah is
critical but
difficult
joseph thank you so much that was a
really tremendous
presentation so on behalf of everyone
thanks everyone for coming today the
attendance was great
very well done joseph and thanks
everyone for attending
awesome thank you so much everyone have
a great rest of your week
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu